the whole subject is walking on on water
sort of and for me I'm walking around
another subject
um and and what
yeah
is that not the right yeah no no it's
great
but so you gave an amazing introduction
to us with her in the sense that that I
can see where where all the all the you
know what's headed under the rock but
um the beginning of
the you know when moving to the to the
introduction of
the formula and the Hilbert face and the
the boundary Theory
um
there it sort of came as a as an action
that is there and and I wanted to
understand what's what's sort of the
story what is it that you're requiring
from both from the field theory that
you're putting there as well as from the
correspondence so that we know that it
works yeah okay so that's a good
question I swept it under the rug on
purpose because it was using techniques
that I didn't want to get into uh in
this lecture but in order to derive a
formula like this
basically what you need
um
is or the where it comes from as you
think of the bulk Theory
as a quantum gravity Theory right that's
or at least that's what we're thinking
uh and you have to make the assumption
that to do calculations uh in this
quantum gravity Theory you can you can
calculate the expectation values of
observables and partition functions
using a path integral
uh and so a natural way to prepare
States you know like the ground state
thermal States in a physical Theory
um is using the euclidean path integral
I guess
where's Anthony yeah he told us how
about how to prepare forestates a very
similar idea
um and in the case of the gravity Theory
well we imagine that there's a
microscopic degrees of freedom
right
um
and
we we think there are microscopic
degrees of freedom but a way that people
have thought about doing quantum gravity
going back to Hawking in the 70s and
saying
um let's do the path integral over the
possible geometries
right so those are not actually the
microscopic degrees of freedom like the
geometries are are macroscopic things
um but
if you think of the gravity Theory as
being some kind of semi-classical object
then one would hope that this would be a
reasonable way to you know to do the
semi-classical gravity Theory
um and so there's a prescription which
goes back a long way uh to doing these
some over geometry path intervals you
know for euclidean path and girls to
repair States and then uh real-time
integrals to do time Evolution
um and if you take that prescription to
be valid
all right you can calculate partition
functions which are things like traitia
Trace row
um you can take Trace rho squared and
Trace row to the N so you can get
entropy-like functions and you take the
limit and goes to one you know
appropriately uh and you get the Von
Neumann entropy and so you can you know
you can look inside the guts of this
path integral and that's a lot of what
actually happened you know over the past
you know 10 years like people really
thinking not just in the case of an
anti-decider but even asymptotically
flat space
um what does the path integral look like
and seeing that you could extract this
formula that looks like ryutakinagi for
the entropy
um and so there's a lot of work there
which I'm not an expert on really how
you do that kind of stuff but it's it's
Justified uh those calculations are
believed at the same with the same level
of belief that uh
basically you can trust the
semi-classical summer of a geometry's
path integral
I think basically
you know what is this minimum you know
it's a saddle point calculation in in
Summit path integral somewhere
but do you expect this vehicle
and formula
before any
in some space like me that's nice if you
add you look at the field theory on the
battery and we expect that whenever
there is a correspondence which
satisfies something maybe even even
outside of ads yeah yes
um what would satisfy yeah formula that
looks a lot like this I mean you have
this is a simplified version yeah
because uh it's not covariant like I've
chosen a specific time slice and so on
if we get there towards the end of the
talk I'll write down what the you know
what the
covariant you know general formula is
um but yes
right
information why this makes sense to take
the material over the possible
um
yeah yeah
so
why that makes sense
um maybe we can take that offline I
think that's something I I want to think
through a little bit myself like I think
we could come up with
analogies
um where you have a semi-classical
theory
um and you know some sector of the
theory is behaving is basically obeying
the classical equation classical
equations of ocean uh and then
um
I think actually that's basically though
is that
yeah but let's take that discussion a
little bit offline
um
okay so I do want to get into black
holes a little bit
um and in this correspondence
um so empty ads was the ground state uh
of the boundary theory if you talk about
a thermal state
of the boundary Theory oh then you get a
black hole
and
a black one of these mixed States uh you
know the thermal state is a mixed state
so it's natural to purify it and you can
purify it in the energy eigen basis
um you get a sum over energy eigenstates
you take the square root of the weights
uh oops not h
the energies
and there's a purification and people
like to call this the thermo field
double
the you know Quantum information we
might call this the canonical
purification uh but just it's just
natural purification of the thermal
State and we could ask what does the
yeah what does this look like
um
so the geometry Associated to this state
at time equals zero
um looks something like this
um and so here's the CFT right which is
a ring
um
and I purified so I have a left CFT and
a right CFT so there's another circle on
this side
uh and there's actually uh space
connecting uh those two boundaries right
and it's a it's it's topology is the
topology of a cylinder uh and so this
thing is actually a wormhole
right that's what the the geometry of
the purification ends up looking like
um so
why is there space connecting the two
um
so there are again there's a story about
how you extract the metric yeah from the
boundary observables
uh and one of the boundary observables
in the conformal field theory is
something called the stress tensor and
so there's a prescription for how you
extract the metric uh from the you know
from the conformal field from the field
theory state
um and so of the connecting space
um
yeah yeah
I mean in general right but in in the
specific in this specific case it gives
you this geometry
um I kind of say one couple of little
things about this so the energy
eigenstates you know this is a thermal
state so if you have a thermal state of
some very large uh you know huge number
of degrees of freedom uh if you choose a
random energy eigenstate
its expectation values are going to be
pretty much the same as they are for the
thermal state
and so any one of these energy
eigenstates
um
looks pretty much the same uh for
observables that we would that we would
measure on one side
right I don't think who you told us
what is left
oh uh well
right is there there was a CFT a ring a
ring of cutits right and we purified it
I guess it was left here the energy
eigenstates we purified that uh that CFT
with another copy of itself
right so for any for every energy
eigenstate
um we wrote down another energy
eigenstate in the second CFT so that it
means that if we Trace overwrite uh in
this thermal field double State we get
the thermal state
on the on the left right so there's just
two mirror copies of each other
um
why do we uh I'll get there right
um right now it's right now it's a
wormhole is all we all we know about it
um so sorry sorry but so so far so far
you've just just have the the ring on
you know uh of uh widgets and then we
verified it so you've got these two yep
and so far we only have we have the
right to think of the boundary as just
those two
the boundary is two rings now yeah and I
just turn them on their side so I can
draw the picture like this huh and and
and now you're you're showing us the
um
but but now you're you're showing us
where this one okay you know the band
The Boundary part of the world or
something uh so what I'm showing you
know
so this is
boundary boundary one yeah
boundary two
and then there's a single bulk
uh and the single bulk is connected
Patrick couldn't we derives that the two
boundaries are connected like using some
entropy calculations plus the
ryutakinagi form that's not how it was
originally derived but we could uh yes
uh we will yeah
um
that are more or less a result right
yeah
are there part of the boundary or the
bulk they're the bulk okay yeah sorry so
the
the boundary the left boundary is this
ring okay the right boundary is this
ring and then everything inside is is
just called
um
so one thing to observe
though is that if I just take one of the
energy eigenstates say on the left right
that's a state of the left CFT
right
um
so it's going to it's going to have some
bulk right the expectation values of any
observable that I'm likely to measure on
the left CFT are going to be the same as
they would be in the thermal state so in
particular this region of the bulk uh
should exist for one of the you know for
a typical one of those energy
eigenstates
um but somehow it's not going to be
connected to the right
and so
this is an example where if I take a
bunch of disconnected geometries right
if I have an energy eigenstate on the
left energy I can stay on the right if I
look at their product state that that's
going to be a pair of disconnected
geometries but I take a big enough
superposition of them
and they represent a spatial a connected
geometry
so this is a situation in which
entanglement is leading to the creation
of space
so Lenny likes to say ER equals epr
Einstein rosenbridges wormholes are
equal to Bell States uh I don't know if
that's supposed to be an analogy or a
metaphor uh but this is a situation
which it actually happens
how do we see that they're connected
okay so again I'm not gonna I can't do
that calculation but in the CFT
uh again there's a prescription coming
from the story that I was telling you
before about how you extract the metric
in the bulk from the stress tensor and
the boundary and so you just you know
you just turn that crank and you find
the metric
um
or as Scott was saying
um if you follow the prescription that I
just told you about where entropies come
from
right we can start calculating entropies
to to figure out whether the bulk is
connected or not
because you know yeah we know that the
bulk is related to geodesics or the
entropies are related to geodesics in
the bulk
um okay so can I ask one more question
yeah so how should I think of this
picture now should I think of it as a
nice trick that you did like is the is
the Wormhole real oh is it just
something that you are now you know
this is a matter of taste okay so this
is a little bit of matter taste right if
you want to take the pers you know if
you don't want to have your uh your
world view shaken too much then you just
take the point of view that all we want
to do is find ways of doing calculations
in conformal field theories
and we find there's an effective
description involving gravity you know
the stress tensor gets mapped to the
metric it said blah blah blah right and
you just say okay well in my effective
Theory
there's a wormhole
and then you can go home and you sleep
at night and yeah there's nothing to
worry about uh but yeah this could have
implications for the way that you think
about the structure of yeah our world
yeah
um in the first part your bulk had a
very nice coordinate system so oh yeah
you want to see coordinates is there a
coordinate system here okay let's load
down some coordinates
um so the entanglement wedge
is
uh oh I do want I did want to talk about
the entropy
um so let's calculate the entropy of the
entire right CFT
okay
so I want to take you know my region a
is this whole circle
uh and remember the the homology
condition says that I should think about
bulk regions uh whose
uh all right I should think about curves
gamma when I take the the union of the
boundary and Gamma I get a bulk region
okay
and so the squiggly gamma would be
allowed and also this one around the
waist of the Wormhole is allowed uh and
the way I've drawn it you can kind of
yeah it's meant to be suggestive uh I
drew the curve around the narrowest yeah
part of the Wormhole uh and that will
actually give me the entropy the length
of that curve
um and so the entropy of the CFT is one
over four Newton's constant the length
of gamma
and this is Hawkins formula right for
the entropy of a black hole the entropy
is supposed to be the area of the
horizon
this waste it turns out is the horizon
um so this ryutakinagi formula
generalizes uh Hawking's formula
uh
so we could say that they the two
boundaries must be connected because if
they weren't connected then the entropy
of each boundary would be zero yes and
yeah although that logic
suggests that any purification of the
the right CFT will give me a connected
geometry and that's probably overstating
the case right Lenny might say such a
thing but yeah I think there are a lot
of additional conditions on the state
before you can interpret as a hormone
hmm isn't that what Scott said just the
truth I mean if you do get enough
geometry then if you define a wormhole
as entanglement
well then yes or you could say or you
could say maybe it's only valid if we
start with a globally pure State
um you know if we don't in in that in in
physical reality you have a pure state
that we're not allowed to do well so I
think here's here's another a counter
argument right take take the state that
we just talked about this uh thermal
field double yeah yeah and then apply
a high random unitary transformation on
the left yeah right so now you've
completely messed up the geometry the
degrees of freedom are all mixed
together
um I would not expect there to be any
kind of smooth geometry interpolating
from the right to the left
right um and yeah it takes a radical
redefinition of what you mean by a
wormhole uh and actually I was going to
call on you at this point right hello so
there was this controversial experiment
a little while ago which people asserted
that they made a wormhole in Black right
and
um Scott had a good quote in the New
York Times what did you say exactly I
said you know if if we're gonna say that
this brought a hormone to actual
physical reality because they simulated
it on a you know nine cubic quantum
computer then why not say that I bring
one into reality when I just draw like
two curved lines
so I'll interpret what you said all
right as a version of what you know I
was suggesting entanglement is necessary
for the geometry but it's not sufficient
um
okay uh so there's a question you know
coordinates what's your blank in the red
box
oh
the entangling wedge is the horizon
why is this
is
black hole
um
Okay so
anyway so right well remember I was just
telling you you can infer the metric
from the stress tester so the metric is
the bulk quantity the stress tensor is
going to be the boundary can form a
field Theory quantity and the metric you
infer if you just throw in the thermal
state is this one
and this metric which might not mean
much to you but you can see you know
there's a Time
the time portion and a spatial portion
radial and angular right because it's
two plus one dimensional bulk uh and
there's a coordinate singularity
at little R equals Big R
right
and it's not a real singularity in the
space time but at this point that little
R equals Big R that is the Horizon of
the black hole
I'm missing the label
the labels of what T and R are five oh
sorry yeah
yeah so I don't have to tell you what
the coordinate you can sort of
there's no time in this picture yeah
it's just space uh and the let's see
um the radial coordinate it takes you
around the CFT uh and the angular or the
or sorry the angular coordinate takes
you around the CFT the radial coordinate
is kind of brings you inside
um and this metric if you analyze it you
know it does involve time uh and it
looks it's like it's basically the short
Shields black hole stuck inside ads I
would have time to go into it but um
that's what this this thing is and so
you infer as I was saying from the uh
boundary state that there's a black hole
there
um
and I have a few comments about these
parameters right uh
the mass there's little L this is the
radius of curvature of the ads space
which I've set to one before but now
I've included it Newton's constant the
mass of the black hole so
um the radius and the black hole grows
as the mass grows as you would expect oh
and the black hole has a temperature
um which
um
goes down with the mass
okay
um
unless
it corresponds to a black hole so tiny
that it doesn't reach equal yeah it
can't be an equilibrium
um because this is this issue that we
talked about you know the
um the black hole radiates the radiation
goes out to The Boundary it comes back
it gets reabsorbed and so you uh
this does not describe an evaporating
black hole
it describes it yeah a
static black hole beta is the in-person
temperature it is the inverse
temperature
yeah I thought that the temperature
should be inverse but the radius oh it's
different yes yeah so the bigger you
make the black hole the hotter it gets
oh
relative to the Eds Steel
yeah no yeah
okay
so
I do want to
present this picture though
uh so this
this metric here
uh it has this radial Direction R
greater than zero and so it really just
describes one side of the picture right
um but you can take that metric uh and
analytically extend it
right that there's a there's a bigger
metric and what you find is a black hole
with two outsides right uh so you could
fall into the black hole from the right
and you could fall into the left but
when you meet in the middle
um and this is a picture that kind of
describes the causal structure that this
is a particular set of coordinates that
takes all of Infinite Space and squeezes
it into a finite box here
um and
time goes up from left to right so
there's a Time on the left
thank you
I have to remind my pen
there we go
that's connected
so in this picture this is a particular
set of coordinates yeah
enabled lnr related to the constants in
the metric are they related to
Eleanor oh uh no sorry l r here just me
left and right
so they're not constants they're just
yeah
yeah I think I still don't understand
the coordinate system very clearly well
like what takes you from what's the
radial direction does it move you within
one CFT or does it go from
it doesn't go all the way from left to
right
the metric only covers a portion of the
space time basically this upper right
portion in this picture but I'll explain
this diagram in a second or right now
so this is you know there's some set of
coordinates yeah very curved in which
the black hole looks like this uh and
now time goes up from left to right so
the entire CFT is just a point so at
every Point there's uh
or rather the
yeah
um
so every bulk Point
there's a whole circle
um
and
right
we get Horizons of the black holes of
these dotted lines and in this set of
coordinates they're very nice because
light rays travel at 45 degrees
okay
and there's see the singularity of the
black hole is supposed to be up at the
top and so if you're inside if you're in
this region here
any signal that you can send out
has to travel inside this uh this wedge
from 45 degrees to the left to 45
degrees to the right and so any single
that you send is going to hit the
singularity all right so this is the
interior of the black hole
this is the right outside if you're on
this side if you just sit where you are
eventually you land inside
uh
and likewise on the right and two uh two
light rates left on the right can eat in
the middle right so the uh this is this
region here which from the outside looks
like a black hole it is a kind of a
wormhole from the left side to the right
a non-traversable wormhole right because
there's no way to start here and travel
uh
at the speed of light or slower and end
up on the other side right if you start
here travel the speed of light you hit
the singularity you're not able to get
out of the other
s and so this is the it's called the
Penrose diagram describes the causal
structure
of this uh two-sided black hole
it's a in this these lectures uh I want
to show you how you can calculate things
okay so I gave you a metric here and
then I asserted that you can find
coordinates that cover
both sides at the same time right the r
and Phi coordinates do not
um
but there are something called Crush
call coordinates
and they look a lot like this Penrose
diagram
the
yeah
again light rays travel at 45 degrees
that's U equals zero this is one horizon
the black hole the other Horizon the
interior region
the right exterior region
um and except that the The Singularity
occurs at U times V equals minus one
and the boundary occurs at U times V
equals one so the boundaries here are
hyperbolas and this hasn't squashed
everything down into a finite box
because the space time extends that to
Infinity you know in these UV directions
but it looks yeah it looks a lot the
same and I'm just going to flash this at
you because you know we don't really
have time to go through it but here uh
is the formula that relates the RT and
Phi coordinates to the U and D
coordinates
okay and so yeah if you have yeah if
you're comfortable with the the RT
coordinates you could use this to
calculate the metric or you can look it
up and so on and so forth right so this
is uh this is the metric of this
two-sided black hole and it can be
inferred directly from the CFT state
and what's nice about this particular I
also Define these T1 T2 X1 X2 this is
some embedding of the two of the
three-dimensional geometry in a
four-dimensional geometry and it's nice
because there's a very simple formula
for the geodesic distance in terms of
these x's and T's
so there's the formula for the distance
between 82 points in the Wormhole
geometry okay
I can't really imagine it being much
simpler than this
reasonably simple and again we can stop
and think how would you know how would
you prove this oil of LaGrange equations
that's how you do this
okay so what do we find
um
here
uh if we just take this formula for the
geodesic distance we could ask what is
the distance from the left from a point
on the left to a point on the right at
the same angle you know at the same
angular
yeah
see at the same time I'm like well at
the same angle fire
um and you work out there's this formula
here
um and let's just say that we're going
to talk about the same times on the left
and the right so if T is T left and T to
your right
I'll be right there
we want to take this formula we want to
know what the distance is
we have the log of the hyperbolic cosine
again if the argument of the hyperbolic
cosine is Big it's just the exponential
so the log of the hyperbolic cosine is
just nothing or it's just you know a
null operation and so we just have the
radius times twice the time over twice
the radius of curvature so we have
radius of the black hole time
the square of the radius of curvature
and so
what this what we see here is that this
black hole or the Wormhole and from the
outside the black hole just sits there
doing nothing
but the inside of the black hole is
changing as a function of time it's
getting longer and longer and longer and
longer its length is proportional to the
time which we asked uh we look and so
this geometry is not static yeah it's
it's changing and you get a question
yeah
became in the basics I don't understand
so so he started from a black hole later
you argued why it's uh related it's
equivalent to thermostat and then we've
purified it as I mean to me a formal
operation to me it seems like an
abstract I mean just uh a mathematical
operation
purification as a mathematical as a
physical thing as if it exists there
is this under the assumption that that
this thermostat comes from truly pure
state
in physics
right so the the reasoning goes that if
I purify the thermal state
um
as a state of another CFT
in the way that I did
um then I can still use the abs-cft
correspondence to go from the metric of
this the new CFT consists of two rings
instead of one I just thinking that you
can be like superimposed right on top of
each other instead of acute it's you
know instead of D it's now D Squared
right so it's a new CFT but I can use
the same rules to infer the bulk metric
so I use those rules and this is what I
find
two the two boundaries as if they do
exist in
um yeah I mean let's just take the you
know The Pedestrian we're doing
conformal field Theory and we want the
effective description right
um and so we just turned the crank we
say we have a conformal field theory
that has two
um two subsystems that I'm calling left
and right
um but together there's one uh one
stress tensor and I go from the stress
tester to the metric and the metric is
this one
so it's this much has been around for
30 years or yeah close to yeah
yeah you have to treat it as a single
object
you're not stitching things together no
no so does this implies that the entropy
of the vehicle is increment
so we can use this account yes uh well
let's let's okay thank you for the segue
let's calculate the entropy
so the well the entropy of the black
hole
um we worked out up here the area of the
the entropy of the black hole if we look
at this metric which covers
the right hand side
there's no dependence on time
right I mean uh if you have a
there's DT but there's no no dependence
on T right there's a dependence on my
radial position here but there's no
dependence on t and so this tells me
that uh
the anything I can measure only on the
right
um
is going to be it's not going to change
with time
that the black hole looks like it's
static from any one side
um so it all the only thing that's
changing is inside
so let's calculate the entropy
and in particular sorry uh the black
hole entropy stays the same
but things do change and so the kind of
thing that we can ask about is let's
take
a region a which is half of the left
boundary a region B which is half of the
right boundary I try to evaluate the
joint entropy s of a b
um
so now we're going to have to apply that
homology condition again
um
can anyone give me a candidate yeah so
you know so what do some candidate bulk
gamos Vault curves that could be used to
calculate the entropy look like right so
they have to satisfy the condition that
a union B Union my bulk curves are the
boundary of a bulk region
oh okay so dorit has a proposed
she did not propose that
she propose this
so there's an example right the yellow
region uh the boundary of the yellow
region is a b Union Gamma One Union
gamma two so that's perfectly good and
what's another option
yeah okay
um there's the there's another option
um
and so
the first configuration
um do you think it's going to dominate
for Early times or late times
right so we learned that the Wormhole is
getting longer and longer as time
increases and so Gamma One and Gamma 2
are getting longer and longer and longer
as time increases so at some point yeah
well I should say gamma 3 and Gamma four
they never they never enter the black
hole
and so the likes of gamma 3 and Gamma 4
never change
So eventually Gamma 1 plus gamma 2 is
larger than gamma 3 plus gamma 4. so
the first comment uh first configuration
dominates for Early Times
and then the second configuration
dominates for late times again how is
the Sterling field double State evolving
that just that
phases
that's it all of quantum mechanics is
only phases yeah yeah yeah
it's fine yeah okay yeah and so what
does this mean
well if we think about the mutual
information uh of a with B that's
entropy of a plus entropy of B minus the
joint entropy
um
once we reach saturation
what happens we have this configuration
right uh and the joint entropy is the
entropy of a plus the entropy of B
so the mutual information is zero for
late times
and greater than zero during the growth
phase
and so that's what happens with a black
hole
um
and
sorry once the Wormhole is so long that
you know we never want June designs to
straddle the Wormhole then how can we
continue to use entropy to calculate
what's going on or tell us
longer
maybe we can't actually so there are
other quantities that are calculated by
geodesic certain kinds of correlation
functions and you'll see the correlation
functions they Decay exponentially with
the length of the geodesic so those
things will continue to change but I
think you're I think you're right
actually in this case it saturates yeah
at a given time right okay so you stop
learning anything
all right
you'll see here Prime irreversibility
uh
we don't we don't see time
irreversibility the the prediction would
have to be that when the phases uh you
know all line up again like they were
before then the Wormhole has to shrink
oh sure yeah okay so there there's an
issue yes which I I swept under the rug
which is that
um if there are finite number of degrees
of freedom effectively in the control
field Theory eventually we get
recurrences at some enormous times in
the future
um and so there's some time after which
the gr description no longer ceases to
be ceases to be valid uh it's not very
well understood yeah how long that is
um but
it has to break down eventually for that
for exactly that reason
okay so there's been no complexity so
far in this discussion but it's time to
introduce a little bit of complexity
and this is suskin's puzzle
okay so we have uh this two-sided black
hole which is really a wormhole and
we've learned that the length of the
Wormhole grows linearly as a function of
time for exponential times and then you
know something strange might happen
um
and as we were just discussing
the entropy or the joint entropy the
mutual information this saturates early
right in linear time
I'll just say in polynomial time
and so he just asked the question
what is the boundary holographic dual
of the bulk Wormhole length exactly what
Scott was asking uh because he wants
some you know some
let's call it measurable provisionally
you know some quantity in the bulk that
correspond or in the boundary that
corresponds to bulk worm bowling we're
both Wormhole length is a pretty
straightforward observable
in in the uh in the gravitational Theory
right it's one of the simplest things
you can write down the shorter you know
like the shortest pass between two
points
um and so a general rule in this ads CFT
game is that natural quantities on one
side have some natural description on
the other side and so he wants to know
what is the boundary holographic dual
bulk Wormhole length and
back in 2014
he was thinking about this and he said
okay
he needs a quantity that will grow
linearly with time for time exponential
in the number of qubits and the number
of degrees of freedom and he scratched
his head looking for a quantity that
would have that property and what he
came up with
was
computational complexity
um of the CFT state so relative to this
thermal field double if you start at the
thermal field W you can ask how much
additional how many additional gates are
required to convert that state into the
the state at some later time and he said
that should be uh
the boundary Duel of Wormhole length so
let's just check that that makes sense
is it a CFT property right there's a
hamiltonian in the CFT we can trotterize
it or use some fancier method of
hamiltonian simulation uh and if we use
it yeah an optimal method of hamiltonian
simulation the number of gates will be
proportional at the amount of time that
we have to simulate for like well okay
it checks out in that very limited sense
but when Lenny proposed this to me back
into that sorry he suggested I thought
he was crazy yeah he suggested a lot of
uh
bold things in his lifetime but this one
just seemed completely unfounded right
like what yeah oh you want something
that's you know grow is proportional to
time you say what could possibly be
proportional time computational
complexity and that was basically the
argument at that point
and
oh okay
um but
oh okay so I I said a bunch of this
stuff already right so
um if we say that the state at time T
I'll call it PSI of t
um we get it by evolving from the
thermal field double state for an amount
of time T there's a hamiltonian on the
left hamiltonian on the right you do a
hamiltonian simulation on this thing
hamiltonian simulation on that thing the
number of gates is going to scale
proportionally to the time
um
and if there's no shortcut to that
hamiltonian simulation
and these These hamiltonians are chaotic
right and chaotic in some very strong
sense and so there's no reason to think
that there is a shortcut but if there is
no shortcut you know then
yeah this statement is true
um and it was later revised you know for
reasons we couldn't get into into not
the Wormhole length but the Wormhole
volume properly defined being
proportional to the Circuit complexity
but again
what flimsy evidence yeah like why would
anyone believe such a thing uh well you
know after he proposed this
um
he and Douglas Stanford building on work
that uh Douglas Stafford done with Steve
Schenker on shockwaves found that you
know there is more evidence
so
this is gonna be the story of shock
waves with these black holes
um and I think I'll end after this uh
but imagine sending a few uh a few
photons
at energy
the same order as the temperature yeah
so you're not sending in very hot
photons you know very energetic photons
you're uh you're sending in photons that
might be like 10 times the uh the
temperature
right five times and then you ask and
you you know they're you're sending them
into the black hole they'll be absorbed
by the black hole the black hole will
grow by a little bit but if the if the
energy of these photons is small
compared to the mass of the black hole
you wouldn't expect much to happen
right
um
so the picture is something like this at
some time in the past TW you send in
some photons they enter the black hole
the black hole absorbs a little bit of
extra energy black hole grows a little
bit yeah no big no biggie
um
but it turns out
that there is a very large Blue shift uh
because of the curvature and the
geometry and in the frame which is
relevant to talking about the interior
of the black hole right these crushed
call coordinates
um you find that there's a massive blue
shift right growing exponentially with
how long in the past you sent in these
photons and so the exterior geometry is
barely affected but the interior
geometry is is strongly affected
um
and again
I just want to sketch to you how you do
these kinds of calculations
so
here's that Crush call picture there
were some coordinates that I I spoke
about I spoke about at some time in the
past TW you you send in this you know
you said in this little uh energy pulse
it enters the black hole right but when
it enters the black hole you should
think of it as being incredibly
energetic okay uh and it's a shock wave
and so what you end up having to do
mathematically to deal with this
situation uh
on one side of this of the of the shock
wave you have the crush call coordinates
on the other side you also have your
crush call coordinates uh but they
describe different black holes actually
you don't have to really talk about
Shockwave too much on the left hand side
where we drop the pulse the black hole
is now Mass M plus e
on the right hand side the black hole is
seen as having mass m so you have to
glue these two solutions together
and so when you glue geometries you
could ask well what do I need to do when
I glue geometries remember there's a
circle an angular Direction which is
suppressed in this picture
so the radius of the circle should be
the same as you cross that uh that
gluing and then you also want time to
flow continuously yeah the proper time
experienced by an observer who crosses
that cut to increase continuously so you
just use those two gluing conditions and
you get a new metric okay and the new
metric it really does just look like two
two glued
um crushed Gall wormholes but with a
shift right so here is uh the past
Horizon of one and it doesn't match up
with pasteurizing at the other so
there's there's a yeah it just looks
like the the it looks like the geometry
on the left
but someone who crosses the shock wave
gets bumped discontinuously to another
look at you know to a different
coordinate and so you know I just want
to sketch that out like this is
something that it's it's described in
the Schenker Stanford paper in detail
and you can you can follow it if you
like
um
but once you've done that again we care
about uh geodesics right
and I gave you a formula for the length
of geodesics in the in this Wormhole
geometry
um but now there's this kink
so if I have two boundary points like a
boundary Point here and a boundary point
there
if I want to calculate the geodesic
distance
I have to optimize
over the points at which they hit the
kink right so there's a one parameter
family of
of geodesics that I have to optimize
over it I find the minimal length right
and here's the answer
there is the the length of the new
Wormhole
um
um and what is there to say about this
uh the difference shrinks exponentially
with time
so let's just think about the time T
equals zero
and so the distance has this extra piece
Alpha
right
and what does alpha look like energy
over Mass exponential in the time that
we dropped in the perturbation
and so an exercise for you
because the rate wanted exercises
set time equal to zero and express the
Wormhole growth the log of alpha in
terms of the time at which we dropped in
the perturbation the entropy the energy
and the inverse temperature
um so and I wrote down formulas for all
those things
and what you get
as your answer
is that the the volume or the length
goes as
the time in the past at which you
dropped in the perturbation
minus twice this quantity two t star
so
so the volume doesn't start growing
until you know there's sort of a delay
before the volume starts growing right
and T star
is this quantity known as the scrambling
time inverse temperature times the log
of the entropy
so this came up for example in my paper
with John presco about about black holes
it's a very important quantity uh it
gives us the the time scale for
information to become fully delocalized
in the black hole uh and are in the
boundary Theory
um and so this is some formula and it's
now
more interesting it's a more interesting
formula than just saying that uh volume
grows with time proportionally right
it's saying that the volume uh it was
growing with time but if we fix the time
and then we think about dropping into
perturbation there's a very specific
form
uh describing how the uh the volume
should change
and we could compare this against the
computational complexity uh hypothesis
right because T Star right involves the
log of the entropy yeah it's a you know
it's a
it's something
non-trivial wait I mean couldn't
couldn't that formula predict that the
volume should be negative
um
so let's say the growth is zero or this
is only for for TW significantly larger
than T star
okay
because I was neglecting
this yeah
I think I was neglecting well yeah
okay so why is this another it's not a
check yet right it's a prediction
because we're saying okay
Lenny predicted or conjectured that
Wormhole volume should be proportional
to complexity and he verified it in a
trivial case right where uh where
Wormhole volume was growing like yearly
with time here's a non-trivial case
is
okay well here here's a case where the
more whole volume is non-trivial and now
we have to do the work I'm trying to
estimate uh the size of a circuit uh
that will actually make that state so
let's think about how we would make that
state
um we're interested in the state at time
T equals zero
uh that corresponds to having dropped in
a perturbation at time TW in the past
right so how do we do that we start with
the thermal field double state
we evolve it backwards in time
so this is on the left hand side
we evolved it backwards in time
TW
e so now we have the state on this time
slice
we apply the perturbation which I'm
calling w
and then we evolve forward in time
like that okay and then we get a state
again at T equals zero which corresponds
to what the state is going to be at that
point and so this
this state here I'll draw it as a
circuit
we start in the thermal field double
we apply
the backwards time Evolution we apply
the perturbation
reply the form it's timeout that Forest
High Evolution and if we just looked at
this
um what we would predict would be that
the computational complexity
would be proportional to twice TW
right because it'd be this portion which
is proportional to TW this portion is
just proportional twe
Now can anyone look at this and suggest
a way to do it better
cancels right right so the the right the
right hand purple gates are just the
inverse of the left-hand purple Gates
and so
we can just cancel all of this
with all of this
and we can cancel all of this with all
of this
all right yeah
I mean the size I think
so then it's not proportional to teach
um
that's true depending if I'm keeping
track so maybe I should talk about the
depth
I mean as long as you assume that TW is
large compared to T star then these like
light codes like you'll get a little bit
and then they'll stop isn't that what do
you want yes exactly okay yeah yeah all
right so this this picture is a little
bit this picture's a bit misleading so
let's yeah
let's fix that
um
so we have cancellation outside the
light cone
and the action in the actual model the
circuit is not geometrically local
and so the light cone grows
exponentially with the depth right so I
partially erased this uh x o men
with depth and so we saturate an amount
of time which scales like the logarithm
of the number of qubits
and n
is basically the entropy right the
number of qubits is the the entropy of
the system
and so
yeah
the computational complexity the
relative complexity of converting the
thermal field double State into this
perturbed State
um is
no more
than
TW minus
twice the scrambling time or the
saturation time sorry why don't you get
twice TW because you have the the uh
well you're canceling on both sides
yeah but the kid but we just said that
the cancellation only goes for this
limited amount and then it stops
um
I mean because of the two the two come
the two I think is coming from
uh the fact that there was cancellation
here
and then cancellation here right but I'm
asking why isn't there a two in front of
the TW because we have to apply all the
gates and you know oh I see
okay
actually maybe that's stripe um
so the thing is yeah we have to be a
little bit careful also with the def
like the definition of t star is not
really
well defined beyond that constant
uh or at least the the correspondence
between the scrambling time
and the spreading time yeah there's
there's a hidden constant there right
because uh we want not just for the
information to spread but we want the
information we basically want some two
design type condition right
like we want to
um
we want the information to generate
Quantum error correcting codes or we
want the spreading to generate error
correcting codes so anyways uh I think
there's some a little bit of okay well I
think there's a little bit of wiggle
room on this constant
um Lenny might have a better argument
for why it should be exactly two okay
yeah but I yeah but I still want to know
why there's a one in front of t7w well
because I
yeah yeah I mean the only thing that's
meaningful here is there is the ratio
and I don't think that's fine off the
top of my head I don't know that that's
extremely well defined
um but I'm gonna provisionally say that
Lenny might have an argument for why it
really should be exactly too all right
so anyways now we have we do have some
agreement though right uh the important
thing is that you have to you have this
TW minus some quantity which is
logarithmic and the number of degrees of
freedom
uh and I think that's a non-trivial yeah
that's non-trivial agreement
um it's not a proof by any stretch uh
but it's an indication that they're it's
not completely ridiculous to have made
this conjecture
um and I should probably let you go for
lunch there were all kinds of other
things I was gonna tell you about
particular black hole evaporation uh you
can let the Arbiters decide there uh but
yeah okay so
one thing that I
wish what's your uh
I think I had something here
yeah there was a big uh there's a big
punch line that I won't have time to get
to
oh
no I think I think I should we should
let people have some lunch
okay well the big punch line
okay so let me just uh show you the big
punch line but I won't have time to
really explain it
um
all of this was done
uh all this was done in the context of
uh anti-disitter space right and this is
an abs-cft correspondence but uh it
turns out that a careful inspection I
think we were discussing this of the
formula for Black Hole of for the
entanglement entropy
um it can be applied in asymptotically
flat space
um
and so you can apply it and this is what
Jeff Pennington and others did uh in
2019 to an evaporating black hole
and you can try to calculate the entropy
of the radiation as a function of time
and this is the thing that Hawking
couldn't do
right or it's one of the things that he
couldn't do he didn't seem to be getting
the right answer
um
and when you do the you know when you
look at an evaporating black hole and
you calculate the entropy of the
radiation as a function of time it does
exactly what you would expect a lump of
coal to do okay yeah it uh if the call
started off in a pure state it starts
yeah radiating so it becomes entangled
with its radiation uh but as it burns
itself off it shrinks and eventually
there's nothing left and so the the you
know the the entropy of the lump of coal
goes up and then goes down again and a
black hole does the same thing
that's not very exciting except that we
can do the calculation we actually know
yeah what's going on but the much more
interesting thing is that you can apply
entanglement wedge reconstruction to
this situation
so you can ask uh if I'm interested in
the in the
it's the entropy of the radiation
what does uh where is the extremal
surface that I use to calculate it
and the extremistry you end up having to
use for old black holes an extremal
surface which is inside the black hole
and so there's an entanglement wedge
sitting inside the black hole
which means that if you have an operator
inside the black hole you can
reconstruct it in the radiation
so what do you know this is that's
actually a huge punch line because what
have I just told you I've told you that
this purple portion of the interior of
the black hole is encoded in the
radiation
right what does it mean to be encoded in
the radiation it means that the quantum
degrees of freedom of the interior
are equally well in the exterior
so you would you would think you know
like our our picture of the world is
that there's space here and there's
space there and they're independent of
each other
but in this picture all of this this
entire region inside the black hole
it's
it's accessible outside it's there
there's no distinction between inside
and outside the same quantum mechanical
degrees of freedom yeah if I if I wanted
a Pali operator X measuring a qubit
right here there's a logical palette
operator X and the radiation that will
tell me the answer
and so in the same sense you know that
position and momentum are complementary
degrees of freedom uh in quantum
mechanics they're no longer independent
of each other the interior and the
exterior of the black hole are no longer
independent of each other
and this is something that was
conjectured back in the 1990s but now we
can calculate it we can verify it right
this is I won't call it a fact but under
the you know we've been talking about
this uh some over some over geometry's
path integral under the assumption that
that path integral properly calculates
quantities in quantum gravity this is
the answer the interior and the exterior
of the black hole are not independent
the interior degrees of freedom at least
some of them yeah when they correspond
to the entanglement wedge of the
radiation are encoded in the radiation
itself so the radiation
uh has inside it the interior
um and you might wonder you know
why don't we see massive violations of
causality right because now there was
this you know that was the definition of
a black hole no information inside could
get out again
um it seems to be that the
semi-classical causal structure
predicted by general relativity is
enforced at a practical level uh by the
fact that decoding the radiation would
be exponentially hard
that these are air correcting codes
they're pretty random they're generated
by chaotic uh time Evolutions uh and so
generically the complexity of decoding
we expect it to be hard and that seems
to be how the causal structure is
preserved
do you mean
so violations
the hole should not get it right but
stuff inside the black hole does get out
in fact it's encoded in the radiation
um so that is that is a violation
formerly speaking of causality but you
could ask is it one that would ever
affect an observable
that uh
that we could measure in a practical
sense
right and a practice you know a
condition that you'd want to impose on
uh on the observable would be that you
could Implement a Time polynomial and
the size of the black hole or the the
entropy of the black hole and it seems
that that won't be possible
um we don't we don't know this this is a
this is a conjecture but that seems to
be the nature uh of the sense in which
the causal structure the the old causal
structure preserved by general
relativity survives in you know in this
Theory
um yeah Frank
these are able to send information from
the inside uh well right so not no
because that's right that's that's
that's the part because the the
information gets encoded non-locally
all over the radio or the information
inside the black hole is encoded
non-locally with these uh
in in the radiation all over the
radiation the only way to access this is
to collect an order one fraction of the
radiation do some extremely difficult
exponential time Quantum computation
um and so
but I thought that causality had to do
with sending information
uh yes well so the the sending would be
you send from the inside
to the union of the entire outside of
the black hole
general relativity does not allow that
right if you say you know the there's no
communication from the interior region
to the entire exterior region that that
is happening here but from a practical
perspective there will be no
communication from a location in the
interior to a location
it's going to be too delocalized and
difficult
to extract um and there's been papers
you know thinking about those questions
um but I don't want to keep you for too
long Patrick instructions
um uh yes so
and that's not the same as it's not the
same thing
um so there
there is potentially
let me think
I'm going to put an asterisk on that
because entangle wedge reconstruction
has been demonstrated to a level of
rigor that I'm fairly confident here
that I'm confident in ads CFT
I am not a hundred percent sure that
that has all been done properly and
asymptotically flat space so someone's
looking for a project
I think that's actually a good thing to
sit down and and see that whether the
arguments all go through I suspect they
do
um but if it hasn't been done maybe
that's something some of our group
members should do so in essence
reconstruction would reconstruct
ing code
uh
so now you
instead of talking about a region of the
boundary you're talking you take a
region of the bulk now there there's
only one Theory but it's the radio you
collect all the radiation
and there's a an entropy formula behaves
the same way there which I I you know I
had here but I skipped over yeah
so you just have to make sure that the
the arguments that were made that didn't
really depend much on abs-cft uh also
work you know because they really
entropy arguments at the end of the day
now my intention I have uh Adam teed up
here yeah for the to talk about
complexity
um so there's a lot there's a lot more
interesting things to say about
complexity and quantum gravity but Adam
has coveted so he's not getting that
talk but uh right after lunch therapy is
going to say something I don't know
exactly what about uh complexity and
quantum gravity so hopefully I've set
things up for him
um and maybe I'll end it there and thank
you for your inquisitiveness and your
questions and for slowing me down
um and I'm happy to take any questions
have to go to lunch with anybody
um
that's it
[Applause]
So when you say we do you you identify
these theories and some examples this
corresponds
for bounds like are they filmed
um we don't know that they're lower
balance
um so
under the assumption that there's no
shortcut
um yeah
under the assumption that the only way
to
um
to produce that state which is the
result of this chaotic time evolution of
the hamiltonian
um is to actually simulate the
hamiltonian
um but that's definitely not improved
or rather because it's true trivially
subject to that assumption but that
assumption has not been demonstrated in
any way shape or form
say like the the like the question of
the reversibility of microscopic
Dynamics
uh
which is which basically the resolution
of that sort of semi-parados
is that you don't know I mean the fourth
grade
um
is is it sort of the same type of
resolution basically
if you knew everything
um then everything is reversible but
since you don't know since everything is
local then then then you do see growth
um
so I think I think you can make so you
can certainly talk about some coarse
grained entropy of the Black Hole uh
rather
the entropy of the black hole
they're the coarse grain entropy of the
radiation right we'll just keep on going
up
right like it's thermodynamic entropy
we'll just keep on increasing
um again just like a lump of coal right
or if there's you're burning some coal
uh and you you ask about the yeah
the smoke and the the radiation
byproducts that thermodynamic entropy is
just going to increase proportional to
the amount of stuff you collect over
time
um even though at the end of the day you
have a pure state so the same is true of
the radiation uh I think you know if
that's what you're you're thinking but
um the course grade entropy like you
just if you just look locally at the
radiation and you assign an entropy to
it you assume there are no correlations
and you're just going to get a
hockey-like answer
um and so that's true
um and one thing that's
interesting is that you know the story
to get to the black hole like say the to
calculate the entropy of the radiation
um it involved this long series of ideas
like you know thinking about black hole
complementarity thought experiments
Quantum error correction this Ryu
takianagi formula it's generalization
like there's this whole sequence
intellectual sequence but at the end of
the day uh you you've set up the
calculation to calculate an entropy
right and you do a saddle point
approximation uh using this sum over
geometries which is exactly the exactly
the kind of thing Hawking was doing back
in the 70s and from this perspective he
sort of set up the calculation wrong and
he missed some saddles
right so we just took what he thought
was the dominant saddle and didn't
realize there were these other ones and
so that that sort of formally when and
what you when you look at it that the
one that he thought was a dominant one
was the one that just had no
correlations in it uh that could
actually make the entropy go back down
um and so
that uh
yeah so he you know he could look at the
story now and not know anything about
Quantum air correction but just you know
look at the calculation like oh yeah
okay that's where I went wrong
I should have seen those Saddles I
should have set up I should have
calculated entropy in a different way
yeah
yeah that will say tell me anything
about the cube steak
does it tell you anything about the
United States
so it Keepsake is actually not changing
um
yeah also I think it does tell you
something it's like uh you're probably
aware of this
um
like the thermal field double
I think that G3 Vidal and friends had a
had an algorithm for preparing mixed
States
um of conformal field theories that was
motivated by this connection to
um to where all geometries like there's
they do some identifications in the
tensor Network
um
because these these
these black hole geometries are actually
quotients of ads so you can you can get
at them with identifications so that
there is an algorithm out there with a
running time which probably has improved
but yeah is based on that correspondence
so you're saying that you can prepare
the state you can't trace out if you get
there
yeah
um
thank you
oh
so I've been talking about the
connection between Wormhole length or
Wormhole volume uh and complexity but
this is
um an idea that has been generalized uh
that the Wormhole volume it's some
integral over some region of space-time
and it's actually
um a kind of action a natural kind of
action called the we allergic weight
action uh of the bulk Theory and so the
final version of the conjecture was that
complexity was equal to action
and so I think one of the most
interesting questions for our Quantum
algorithms are complexity crowd is still
to try to prove that
um and it sort of been on my plate for a
long time it looks like a crazy yeah it
looks like the the rankings of a crazy
person like what's the most interesting
thing in computer science complexity
what's the most natural quantity in
physics action it must be the same right
um but action is the phase accumulated
yeah uh in a Time Evolution so it's
naturally Associated to the size of a
circuit right
um and so this is not such a ridiculous
thing to try to identify and I have some
feeling some idea some embryonic ideas
about
how this you know this conjecture may
have been originally made in the context
of quantum gravity but it may be
something much more pedestrian about
simulating semi-classical physics on a
quantum computer
um and so I would love to find some
proof of this in a much more limited
controlled setting uh that just sort of
explain why you know
you know well I mean you can't one say
Okay plainly complexity is at most
action right and the inequality will be
tight unless there is a shortcut uh so
yes except that this action is not that
action
um so this is the action associated with
preparing the state using a path
interval but but I think the answer is I
I still think the answer is more or less
yes okay so but I would like to write
that down carefully so maybe it's kind
of like the situation with the time
energy uncertainty principle and the
read and the OCD is paper right they're
like physicists like assert something
and when they started sort of you know
more or less true but it's true unless
there is a computational shortcut right
yeah yeah and that's that's certainly
going to be the case here this would be
there exists an algorithm to simulate in
which the dominant contribution to the
running time is
um
well yes but
um descriptive complexity just so you
just prepare the state and just do it
for this amount of time
if you mean like complexity or whatever
that's always great right I think you do
mean computational complex
number of games
um but where's the computational problem
was I mean I don't know prepare the
space okay it's important well yeah I
mean actually it's never been entirely
clear to me is it an apparent
in order to apply the unitary
that's like you know in many situations
those will be equivalent right
right you know you can say like they'll
both increase linearly with time but you
know you could imagine pulling those two
apart
um
well it's the complexity of the unitary
well I think it's this relative
complexity yeah the number of gates
required to convert the thermal fuel
double State into yeah okay right but do
we care about the entanglement with the
other half like if if we're tracking the
entanglement you know and we're only
allowing a unitary on one half then say
that because of the Choi Jeremy yakowski
isomarkers
right that like our complexity of our
state preparation problem is just the
complexity of applying a unitary
but if we if we don't care about the
other half then State complexity might
be smaller there might be a shortcut
that's not available if we have to apply
the whole unitary
I mean the state is not maximally
entangled it has the thermal weights and
so if you try to use trojaminokowski to
hop from one side to the other it
becomes non-unitary
okay but another question
um what is the computational power of
quantum gravity and I know Umesh and
some other people and this is going to
come up In fairness talk uh well and
also Bill and Umesh and uh
um
Adam's paper uh
suggested right it suggests that
a quantum theory of gravity
might be able to compute things that are
not possible in bqp
um I think in their paper in in Adam at
all's paper the conclusion is that
either quantum gravity can compute
things that you can't compute in pqp or
the dictionary in abs-cft has to be
exponentially complex
um but it it is an open question you
know how do you even formulate this
notion of the company yeah the
computational power of quantum gravity
uh what is the task
um which observers do you talk about you
know what is what are the reasonable
questions and so
um a context in which that kind of
question has been uh studied in an
interesting way
um
if you set things up correctly in
abs-cft Imagine putting a computer in
the bulk uh and you send in in multiple
inputs from different parts of the
boundary yeah the computer computes
something and then it sends portions of
the output to different portions of the
boundary if you set up the geometry
correctly then what looks like a local
computation in the bulk becomes an
interesting distributed computation in
the boundary and it looks like ads CFT
knows how to do those computations more
efficiently than any protocols known to
the quantum Computing Community
um and so trying to uh Alex May is first
the person's really been pushing that uh
line of thinking it but there are all
kinds of questions about this we don't
even know that we can build a computer
in adsc Ft we don't know that the theory
is Rich enough uh we
yeah yeah
so I mean is there a hope of answering
that question like could one answer it
by just showing that you can build a
universal quantum computer within the
CFT
uh yes you could you could try to answer
the question that way but it's not so
easy to build a universal computer in a
CFT because the excitations are massless
right
um and so you know trying to imagine
trying to everything's too connected to
everything else kind of uh yeah like
like it's hard to get structures that
are going to sit there right yeah right
um yeah so so that
um yeah students are thinking about
those kinds of questions
um they're questions that are relevant
to
um more information theorists
um but the entropies that are being
calculated here are Von Neumann
entropies but the various smooth
One-Shot entropies are of a lot of
interest we want to talk about these
decoding questions and it's not
understood what the duels are of those
One-Shot entropies in the uh in the
covariant uh formulation
um and you know a big question all of
this is done I said asymptotically flat
space ads
um it turns out things are much more
confusing if you have an expanding
Universe uh and but that's what that's
where we live so everything I've said
all bets are off in our universe I
should say right we can't count we can't
calculate anything at this point
um so that's a that's a smattering of
the questions uh there are many more
um but yeah I'd be happy to chat with
people if they're interested brainstorm
good things to think about
[Applause]
thank you